yeah right
welcome everybody it's Friday it's
Friday and you know what that means we
make voodoo dolls out of the hosts of
outnumbered
and punish them for their misdeeds but
first let's welcome tonight's guests
she's so sweet honey bees sue her for
plagiarism host of Fox News Sunday
he has audiences on the edge of their
seats preparing to hang themselves actor
writer comedian divorce dad Jamie lissow
she's got more Hang-Ups than an
automated call about a car warranty
Fox News contributor Kat Tim
and finally when he puts his foot down
he causes millions in property damage my
Master's acting in the NBA's World
Heavyweight Champion
foreign
[Applause]
well thank you for joining us
so before we get to some news stories
it's Friday so let's do this
Greg's leftovers
hmm that's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
so if they suck after the show we will
set fire to Brand kill Mead's backpack
while he's in it
first off a bag of cocaine was
discovered in the white house this week
no one knows the source of the mystery
bag but hunter Biden promised to get to
the bottom of it
cokehead officials say it was found in a
heavily traveled area mostly the area
between Hunter's nose and upper lip
after the drug cachet was described as a
small amount Hunter replied well that
rules me out
I could do these all night probably will
white out security says they'll probably
never know where the goat came from
because they stopped looking
not so much funny as it is kind of a sad
statement of Affairs
thank you Dave
I got a chuckle from the floor director
[Laughter]
just because he's a miserable man
the administration claims that in that
particular location it would be easy for
anyone to abandon an item
security officer reported finding a
grandchild
[Applause]
you got it bag of coke here a gun there
a baby there it's all the same to the
bidens
Harvard announced its most popular
coding class will be taught by
artificial intelligence next year the
university promises the AI will be just
as effective as humans when it comes to
screwing over Asians
I hate racism
just wanted to get that out there
presidential candidate Chris Christie
compared the feud between Ron DeSantis
and Donald Trump to a food fight
he later added that regardless of who
the winner is he hopes there's leftovers
saw that one coming
thank you the newest Mission Impossible
premiered in Australia this week this
time Tom and the Gang faced their most
impossible mission yet to convince
people to see Indiana Jones 5.
you notice that Tom Cruise is gaining a
lot of weight
over the holiday weekend Chicago hosted
its first Nascar event it went pretty
well too only four of the drivers were
carjacked thank you
Joseph pedot the marketing whiz behind
chia pets and their iconic commercials
has died at the age of 91. but his
family plans to grow him back in one to
two weeks
a new government report outlines
research options for blocking out the
sun due to global to slow down global
warming it even included an artist
rendering of what sun-deprived humans
might look like in a hundred years
according to a new survey Millennials
are the biggest Liars of any current
generation you know I was just talking
about that with my ex
[Laughter]
she can't keep a secret
finally a new trend shows that receiving
filler shots for penal enlargement
sorry Shannon
it's now on the rise
yeah but it doesn't work for everybody
said one man
[Applause]
all right that was mean
me
mean
Shannon needs another jacket yeah get
Shannon another jacket she needs to
readjust it again yes all right we gotta
go we're gonna do the news the White
House can't explain the mystery cocaine
but isn't it handy that they can't find
the owner of the nose candy it's been
almost a week since a small bag of coke
was found inside the West Wing
specifically a quote heavily traveled
area security says they'll probably
never know where it came from which
means they know exactly where it came
from Politico was quick to regurgitate
that claim just three days after the
discovery citing a law enforcement
official probably one of the same
officials who signed that letter
dismissing Hunter's laptop as Russian
disinformation
The Source said even if there were
surveillance cameras unless you're
waving the coke around it may not have
been captured on tape
note to self don't wave my cocaine
around inside the White House
so you're telling me the White House the
White House
doesn't have the technology to figure
out who left the coke multiple security
checkpoints bomb sniffing dogs
surveillance systems that would make
North Korea jealous and oh we'll never
know
oh well remember January 6th the Dems
played the surveillance tapes on a loop
at the Capitol Building granny's in
overzealous sightseers were swiftly
identified arrested and prosecuted no
Slow Rolling the investigation there
because those weren't Democrats
but when it's cocaine in the white house
we'll never know Kate's closed
but hey it's not the first time the
secret service has been baffled by a
mysterious white substance
[Applause]
I don't get it
I don't get it Shannon
Shannon think about puppies what's Joe
gotta say
no no no look look I don't know who did
this whole deal but I listen I know as a
father that was not Hunter all right
yeah Hunter he's never left a bag of
cocaine anywhere he does the whole thing
in one sitting
and then he turns the bag inside out and
he runs it along his gums
and uh listen
believe me
I know my boy all right he does not
leave bags of cocaine around he leaves
Inside Out empty baggies covered with
his saliva
Jamie as a self-defined comedian uh you
run into uh substances of this manner
all the time is it really that hard to
figure out who did it it's not hard to
figure I was trying to run it down I was
like I don't think it was Hunter because
there was some left over because
um if you if you've ever done cocaine
the correct dosage is all of it yes
um
and then I was like could it have been
Joe and then I was thinking how much
less would Joe Biden have gotten done if
he was not on cocaine this whole time
yes
do you know what I mean and um I try I
tried I can't I can't afford cocaine
Greg why I just the one time I did it I
used my last dollar to buy it and then I
had nothing to roll up and snort it with
laughs
by the way I don't just that joke they
did about the
penis enlargement
um
I was told specifically that fox did not
read our outgoing emails
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and you know you know I'm always like a
positive guy I like to think of my penis
as half full
so Shannon
welcome to the show
four jackets now yes
um as a regular uh user of cocaine
um how do you feel about this being
found in the White House it must disgust
you what do the women of the Bible think
about this we're going to get to that
yes uh but here's the thing not speaking
from experience I just think about how
we're being told like we're never going
to figure this out if you've been to the
White House you know the vetting that
goes in you know for you to get through
it's like social security number where
you were born who you dated in seventh
grade Jeremy Beaver by the way he was
very cute Tom Beaver Jeremy Jeremy not
just oh okay no no Justin Bieber yes I'm
his great grandmother uh girlfriend uh
no but here's the thing they know who is
in these areas
um I think back about you remember when
all these pro-life people they were
doing raids on their houses in the
middle of the night and the doj was like
well it's easier to find them and arrest
them because the people who attack
clinics do it at night yeah it's harder
to see them and try them down this
baggie got left at night we're told it
was Sunday evening so maybe that is
hindering the ability to solve the crime
crimes that happen at night yes
interesting they too bad they don't have
flashlights
[Music]
cat you know this is great for the tour
the White House Tour now like those
White House stores are so boring but now
you go oh this is where
I'm gonna get a picture where the
cocaine was it actually makes the White
House Tour better right
I just wanted to say first of all great
monologue today thank you
you seemed really locked in
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I hesitate to call that an inside joke
but yes I was locked in a room for three
hours before the show because I walked
into a room that didn't have a doorknob
and when it shuts I didn't have my phone
or my laptop I was in that room for
three hours before somebody a friend of
cats came to find out if I was alive
yeah came into my apartment and found
dog everywhere well no he heard you
screaming help so he thought he had
walked into an active murder scene
anyway
yeah everyone thought you died but me
yes I I was like well maybe he had an
argument
he fell asleep no he's dead I couldn't
everyone shunned you for how you'd never
take care of yourself I was like I had I
just it was a good scare to remind me
that I have to have a backup plan you
know like the door with the door you
know it reminded me how important like a
dog door like I should get that doorknob
fixed but how embarrassing would have
been if you'd have been stuck in there
all weekend
This brilliant man writer of many books
was reported and ended by a door with no
knob
just feels like a really unfitting death
yes it was weird it was I tried uh coat
hanger I tried credit card I tried
everything I possibly could even my own
brute strength and nothing nothing would
work and the dogs on the other side
screaming screaming it was it was it was
over three hours three I'd say three and
a half hours of uh alone with your
thoughts yes
do any of you have anything to say about
the topic yeah after I thought you were
dead
yeah she literally took a knee yeah and
immediately called dibs and all of them
which I was upset about yes yes no
listen I think we're missing a big thing
here with this whole cocaine thing
everybody wants to blame Hunter yeah
right okay and and we've laid out the
facts why it's not Hunter uh how was
Kamala not being looked at in this have
you seen her latest speech yeah we got
it next block yeah
like I for months have been saying it's
alcohol
[Applause]
it's you know she's hitting the she's
hitting a lot of things and by the way
that is in the library working on her
speeches yes she's tired
we're gonna talk about that hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else